hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at game 3 from the 1972
World Chess Championships between buddy
Spassky and Bobby Fischer now in Game
one Spassky got the victory after Bobby
Fischer made questionable Bishop
sacrifice towards the end now after that
game Bobby Fischer made some pretty
interesting requests he didn't want any
spectators around he kind of wanted to
play in a back room he didn't want any
cameras and the tournament director said
no we're not going to oblige your
request and Bobby Fischer forfeited he
so Spassky went up 2-0 in the match
Bobby Fischer was ready to leave boarded
a plane ready to go his team was
eventually convinced him to go ahead and
stay and Spassky for whatever reason
decided to go ahead and play game 3 in
kind of this backstage room with no
spectators so that's kind of where we're
at a Bobby Fischer did give up his game
to where he was going to be playing the
white pieces so Bobby Fischer down to Oh
playing in Spassky and Spassky will be
playing the white pieces in game 3
so Spassky starts out with pawn to d4
Knight f6 pawn c4 pawn e6
Knight f3 pawn to c5 so the opening we
don't see it all too often but always
fun to watch upon d5 upon taking a hair
on d5 after the recapture pawn to d6 so
this is the modern benoni if you're not
too familiar it's definitely an exciting
opening because it's usually more open a
Bishop's tend to do a lot better it's
the more aggressive lines than some of
the pawn to d4 openings that you
typically see which are kind of more
closed more positional play this can
lead to some pretty crazy fireworks now
White's really going to be focusing on
the light square so from start to finish
the light squares are very important and
it's all centered around this pawn on d5
right here he wants to maintain control
right here with his pawn and eventually
have a nice little outpost here on c6 e
six and then just dominate his opponent
now on the flip side a black is going to
be looking to counter and dominate the
black score
the dark squares he's eventually going
to fianchetto his bishop here to g7 add
some a little bit more reinforcements
with his Bishop to control those and
then look for a counter push and start
to chip away on the light squares that's
what both sides going to be looking to
do so first we see Knight to c3 pawn to
g6 and then night to d2 now what's
interesting is Knight to d2 is not very
common on at all usually you see pawn to
e4 just strengthening the pawn chain
right here and to serve the board
keeping the knight over on the King side
of the board White has a pretty strong
King side of the board so pawn to e4
even Bishop to f4 now getting this
Bishop outside the pawn chains always
always good Bishop here to g5
potentially is always good then you kind
of have a few options as far as how
white wants to go from here as soon as
Bobby Fischer saw Knight - D - he kind
of switched gears a little bit because
usually if you see pawn to e4 you may
even play Knight to a6 and then
eventually swing him around on the Queen
side you could play pawn to a6 but
you're kind of counter attacking on the
Queen side of the board after he saw
Spassky play Knight to d2 he then played
Knight to d7 starting to kind of look
over here on the Kings side for his
attack now pawn to e4 a Bishop e2 g7
Bishop here to e2 castle on the King
side castle on the King side and then
work over here to e8 putting pressure
the pawn here on e4 it is a backward
pawns does need some protection pawn to
f3 eventually you may want to play this
early on you're not really going to want
to so it does make a lot of sense to go
ahead and start to attack that with his
rook here on e 8 and then Queen to c2
just continuing his developing pieces
and adding another layer of protection
he does have both of his Knights up but
the Queen here of kind of allows those
Knights to do other things on board but
the next move from Bobby Fischer is it's
kind of why he was at the time thought
to be the best player he was over 100
points or rated higher than Spassky even
though Spassky was the champion at the
time but the way he kind of thought
about the game was very different he
plays Knight to h5 and this is a really
weird move this is something that you
would
quickly think that you might see from an
amateur because it goes against
everything that you would expect because
after Bishop takes here on h5 all of a
sudden the pawn takes back there's a
double pawn on the H file that's
definitely not good the King structure
is definitely good for the pawns you can
start to really chip away and attack a
Boppy Fischer played this knowing
exactly what was going to happen he just
felt like he was going to get
compensation for this and so he went
with the plan and he started that plan
ever since he saw that night to d2 and
honestly Spassky wasn't exactly sure how
to play or attack against this he plays
Knight to c4 which I really think you
need to start moving your pieces over to
the King side especially with this
weekend pawn structure moving away from
the King side seems just very very odd I
get that he doesn't want to open up the
door for his darks for a bishop but I
think there's other ways to do that
Knight here to e5 I'm moving his knight
over here to e3 now and then Queen to h4
I think it's just way better if instead
he saved a few moves played Knight here
to f3 that also opens up the door for
the dark square bishop to get involved
and it kind of holds the four down so
the Queen can't come here to h4 but alas
in the game not here to see 495 93 Queen
down here h4 and then Bishop d2 now
Knight g4 there is an exchange on board
and then the pawn recaptures on g4 I
even think that the the night taking is
probably bad you could try something
else here you know you could try pawn to
h3 just forcing the knight to move if
the knight wants to take hey that's
completely fine maybe now you see Bobby
Fischer start to attack on the Queen
side pawn here to b6 pawn here to f3
still trying to maintain control of the
light squares on the board but by taking
here on g4 all this does is give Bobby
Fischer a very powerful pawn here on the
fourth-ranked and it also takes away
stubble pawns which seems absolutely
pointless but upon takes here on g4 now
bishop up here f4 Queen to f6 attacking
the bishop and then pawn to g3 this is
another one of those moves where you
just feel like Spassky doesn't know
exactly how to play in this position
this kind of just chips away at the
light squares that he has on board he
really can't afford to play this he
eventually wants to be playing pawn to
f3 really strengthen the light squares
Bishop just coming back here to g3 makes
way more sense
I still wants to add pressure to the on
the square here on d6 I still wants to
maintain you know pressure with his
Bishop here on this file and so I could
see why pawn to g3 may make sense but he
needs to keep in mind what he's trying
to do in this opening and with the
modern urban ona he just needs to
maintain control of the light squares
but he plays pawn here to g3 Bishop d7
pawn a Ford trying to push on the
queenside recognizing that although he
should have been able to attack on the
kingside he just was not able to pawn to
d6
we're covered here to e1 a6 rookie to
pawn here b5 Rick over here both sides
just trying to maneuver a little bit
starting to attack in the center the
board you do have this backward pawns
here on e4 that both sides you're both
attacking Bobby Fischer is definitely
more in that attacking phase and
spassky's more in the defending phase
right now
Ponyo to b3 rook here to e7 Queen up
here d3 rook b8 after the exchange right
here then we see kind of another
questionable move and it's pawn here to
be 4 this is this one the moves I just
really don't like because after pawn to
c4 this is just very difficult for
Spassky to deal with the rest of the
match this will last Bobby Fischer to
eventually get some nice little outpost
here on b3 or even worse d3 there's just
not much you can do about this and these
are the light squares that Bobby Fischer
really wants to control if he can this
pawn on b4 he has to recognize that
Bobby Fischer is not going to take right
here having a pawn structure in the soon
the boy like this is just bad for
Spassky he could be a lot more
aggressive recover here to a2 starting
to attack on the open file he can swing
his other
over here if he needs to he does have
both of his Queen and his Knights kind
of defending this square so he's fine
right now he doesn't need to play this
pawn here to be four but he does Bobby
Fischer responds pawn here to c4 and the
Queen drops back to d2 Bobby Fischer
plays rook to e8 Rick here to e3 palm
pushing over here h5 rook down here e 2
and then king h7 king f7 is definitely
one of those moves that have me
scratching my head as I looked at it
Bobby Fischer has an aggressive position
he can start to just chip away on the
board and have a much better position
King to h7 it's not really stopping
anything there's no threat that Spassky
has on board he could easily in this
position just play Bishop takes here on
c3 after the Queen takes rook takes
after some exchanging on board Queen
takes and all of a sudden he's
threatening the square here on d5 he's
got a passed pawn right here they can
start putting pressure why can't really
do too much we even see Bishop take here
on d6 well ok this is bad we see Queen
takes on d5 threatening the bishop the
bishop tries anything Bishop back here
to f4 it's all bad news
Queen check all of a sudden the bishop
gets involved c6 pad stuff just starts
happening there's no way to really stop
this even if we come back and say okay
let's say the the bishop does not want
to come back Queen here to c1 we could
if we wanted to just say Bishop here to
c6 threatening mates here and then just
take that Bishop if instead we come back
and say let's let's assume the bishop
doesn't even take right here we could
just see Queen to c1 okay that's
definitely an option right here but they
were just taking this pawn here on d5 so
there's there's nothing really good
that's going to be stopping black right
now this is all kind of bad for white so
that's why I thought he should have done
in the position but instead we see pawn
to h5 broke down here to e2 King to h7
but was interesting as Spassky actually
doesn't have much on board but he
doesn't want to really move pieces away
because he recognizes that it's going to
be even worse for him on board if he
tries
anything to Grady so he just plays rook
back here to III King back here to g8
he says rook down here to e2 let's try
that again Bobby Fischer you played that
King to h7 which made absolutely no
sense I'm gonna give you another shot
you try it again take a mulligan here
Bobby Fischer says okay I found the
right move I'll go ahead and do that so
Bishop town here c3 and kind of the the
variation that we were looking at right
here we do see all the exchange on board
definitely bad at the bishop tick so
Spassky decided to instead play Bishop
to h6 one variation we did not go over
not knowing that it would come up on
board Queen to g6 threatening that
Bishop bishops come back here to see two
but Queen down here b1 is is very
difficult to deal with just putting so
much pressure on white can't really move
as Bishop now this light square bishop
can start to get involved into the board
the Queen can't really do anything
because then the bishop could
potentially fall so Spassky decides for
a different route not the route that I
would go for I really think it needs to
play maybe pawn to f3 just try to shake
some stuff up on board maybe you know
pawned f6 after this we could see you
know exchange
okay now the Queen comes down here maybe
starts to do an attack up to e8 maybe
get some sort of Perpetual check on
board I don't know what you could have
done but instead he decides to play King
over here to f1 any time you want to get
your King involved into the board
get him centralized maybe make him an
attacker on the board it's usually when
your opponent's queen is off the board
when your put its Queen is on the board
and they can just potentially attack and
check and just chase you all over the
board and just start gobbling up pieces
it's very very problematic and I usually
don't want to see Kings rushing to the
center but Spassky decides that's the
best route to go King to f1 Bishop down
here to f5 King to e2 so getting super
aggressive on board Queen up here to e4
Czech Queen over here III now the Queen
back here check the Queen here - D - now
Queen up here to b3 getting ready to
take up the pawn here
queen up here to d4 and then Bishop down
here to d3 check and in this position
spastically actually decided to go ahead
and resign and it's just honestly not
too much this basket can do in this
position if we look at and say okay what
if the King comes down here to e1 okay
well now the Queen takes on before check
after the King moves then the Queen just
starts to come down here b3 we can see
the pawns starting to push forward
there's nothing really y can do to kind
of stop these pawns you can say Queen
here to c2 getting ready for a checkmate
on board if the King comes down hey
that's fine we can sacrifice all day the
King can no longer come here is kind of
this blockade here on d1 d2 d3 and then
we can just start pushing forward and
there's no way to really stop this now
if we come back and say after Bishop to
d3 what if instead we see King starting
to push up King to e3
okay well now just Queen down to d1 is
actually very very problem back there's
no real good way to stop this so much
threats on the board but because this
pawn on c4 is protecting the bishop this
bishop right here is just going to fall
nothing good is going to happen so if we
see King up here to f4
then all of a sudden the bishop falls
and then we can start to push forward
with our pawns eventually all in all
Spassky just did not have anything that
he could do so we decide to resign so
Bobby Fischer actually the first time in
his career that he beat Spassky but he
did beat him beat him with the black
pieces kind of a psychological move to
take him into this back room with no
spectators and beat him so he is down
one game to two wins from Spassky but
congratulations Bobby Fischer in game 3
coming back after he almost gave up on
the tournament so next round we will be
looking at Game four with Spassky
playing the black pieces and Bobby
Fischer going back to the white pieces
trying to level things up at two and two
but hopefully you guys enjoyed watching
we have a ton of games in this
tournament it is a long long term it's
hopefully you guys are enjoying and I'll
see you guys in the next one
thanks for watching